that
i could see people's faces
i don't think faces don't matter what
stage they got to they weren't going to
get in
but that's not the right attitude but
really is the right attitude to have fun
as long as you don't do it on somebody
who
finds it impossible to even move
and then it's rude
uh
psychosis he said you'll be asked to
leave the dojo if he sees you trying to
fight
so there's
there's
there's power and do it and being 100
but if he can't move
then
yeah
okay my turn
that that's completely wrong attitude
but sometimes
we have to overcome that now i had that
bad attitude
and um
i don't know how many years it took me
to
i think i started doing healing work
something completely separate try you
know i think it then started making me
actually think about other people rather
than me me
so
um
so if they can't move
it's his ego i need to help
so i go like that and if he can't move
he says
i think if he doesn't know my name uh
could you do it a bit less
if i go
he can't do it oh i don't have money
while he's off a bit
it's not doing his ego any good because
he doesn't want to say it he doesn't
want to admit that he can't do the
technical move
so i've got to help him to reduce his
ego
so if he can't move he has to
could you please yeah tell me and i'll
go oh all right
so
that's my teaching cytosim she never
touched all that that's that's comes
from me
and you will all be individual teachers
and see and you will teach how you wish
to teach so your aikido is the best
because it's your if you don't
all right so if you can't do anything
today
then
um
then just say
a little bit less please but just do
like ten percent at a time if you can
until they can do it but it's still a
struggle
so that's the way i like to teach
i never teach coda gosh from katadori
because
there's
hands together
one
because it's not basic because
i don't have one hand on him
two
i don't have my hand on him
three i don't have my hand on him
so they're the three categories that i
would teach and that's what we're going
to do today
to start off with
because the coat of guys is this you
open your foot you turn your hand
you catch the inside of his thumb
you do that and you cut down
you bring it over here
we're gonna all do this first because i
want to show you how useless it is
you're in a straight situation just
i'll move my foot sorry i weren't
supposed to move my foot that's the
second stage you move your foot and you
cut it down that's the second stage
the first stage is you turn the hand
i'm having a job getting around there
look at my shape
it can hit me you know there's so many
things wrong with this technique but
because they cycle says you have to show
a basic coat of gosh
this is the basic
so that's what you're gonna do